hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh september 13th 2021
what's going on how are ya
what's up man it's uh i'll tell you what
it is right now it's football sunday
i am uh currently sitting here in my
apartment
i was trying to figure out jesus christ
how to get the [ __ ] directv uh
nfl sunday picket ticket or whatever it
is somehow i ended accidentally i end up
signing up for nfl game pass
which is some international [ __ ] so now
i'm in the country
signing up for international [ __ ] and
they're like well you can't do the
international after i [ __ ] paid for
it they go well you can't do that here
and i don't know i probably didn't read
something
i really want to go out for the nfl and
[ __ ] blame them i'm sure like i just
i've always sucked at that [ __ ]
but i will say that the nfl's [ __ ]
website as far as the directv and
it's just way harder than the nhl the
nba or mlb i just feel like the other
ones it's like hey man you want to watch
all the games uh why yes i do
you got a credit card yeah
all right well if you know the password
and everything you know you hit us with
that number uh you can start watching
right now and it's like okay cool
the nfl they always seem like they gotta
[ __ ] grab you by the back of the neck
you know
like it's not enough that they're making
money they also have to make their dicks
a little hard by like directing you like
there's only one place you can watch
this
you will watch it here
on this service you will have a [ __ ]
satellite drilled into the side of your
[ __ ] house
you know or you can go to a sports bar
and go [ __ ] yourself
dude how funny is it that the nfl has
black lives matter written on the back
of the helmets as they also make most of
you know the predominantly black league
play an extra football game every year
after all the [ __ ] they know about cte
[Laughter]
hey commissioner would it be cool if we
just played one less exhibition game one
less preseason game would that be cool
could we do that man can we do that what
if you played an extra regular season
game yeah see that's what we're trying
to avoid
we'll pay you extra money
what will it cost you
oh it cost us
um
yeah i thought that was bizarre i mean
as a fan i'm happy that they're gonna
play an extra week i'm not gonna [ __ ]
moan and complain about that
um
it also lets me know that the patriots
16-0 regular season will never be broken
[Music]
um sorry so it's uh
what am i i'm watching pittsburgh versus
buffalo right now it's 13 to 10 with 11
19 to go
and i'm kind of finding something
interesting now that i've already bet
all the games that i was going to bet
we'll see how i do now that i mean i was
never really good at gambling but now
that i got a
two kids i'll be even worse at it or
maybe i'll get better because i i won't
have all of this information that i
thought i had back in the day
so um
what's kind of been interesting
is watching uh
you know now that the game is like looks
like it's it's finished is like how did
i not know that trevor lawrence was
going to get schooled the first week
you're a rookie you're brand new they're
going to be throwing all these [ __ ] up
looks at you you're going to get smoked
by houston i was thinking well you know
desean watson's not in the game i don't
know who their backup is and blah blah
blah so you stay away from that game and
then the second you like watch it and
it's like 27-7
all of a sudden you go like oh yeah
now that i have all the answers i can
now fill in the question and it all
makes sense to me
because now i'm watching um
pittsburgh versus buffalo buffalo one of
the most fun teams to watch with josh
allen right there with the reception
um
going up against the crafty wily veteran
that is uh ben roethlisberger and it's
like once again here we go this is his
second year
even though he's a [ __ ] superstar
um josh allen is
you're kind of thinking like i think big
ben's going to get him on this one well
i think uh let's i'll just do this i'll
just say
you know
so i don't have any [ __ ] you know
dog in the fight either way this is the
game josh allen has to [ __ ] win
he's got a if he can beat these guys
these guys who've been in the [ __ ]
league forever
um
that's a great thing because anybody can
[ __ ] not anybody but a lot of people can
burn through the [ __ ] regular season
playing a bunch of [ __ ] bum teams
they're not going to be there in january
but this is a big one i think that if he
goes up against ben roethlisberger who
knows how to [ __ ] win
um
i would be extra excited as a buffalo
bill fit
although it doesn't take them much to
get excited up there considering all the
pain and suffering that they've been
through
let's go back to the early 90s i'm just
[ __ ] with you um
so i have this weird thing now where i i
actually uh
now that brady's gone i kind of root for
teams that i shouldn't be rooting for
like i root for the bills like i like
the team it's
weird i still don't like the dolphins or
the jets
there's just something about the
dolphins uniforms
that orange end zone and [ __ ] i just i
mean i love them when dan marino was
there but they just haven't been
exciting for so long
like when i see like the jets
and the giants like it like that
literally makes my stomach hurt
i've always had that like back in the
day i remember there'd be like different
sitcoms that were on and if i just
didn't like the look of the set i
literally wouldn't watch the show
oh no the steelers blocked the punts
special teams
see now that right there goes to show
you what the [ __ ] i know i just set you
guys up
for the whole battle against the new qb
versus the wily veteran and what happens
the old special team comes in and gives
them the o right there fred
right to the back of the end zone oh my
god
you know what's the only thing the only
thing worse than being a buffalo bill
fan watching your team [ __ ] lose the
opening home game
is when all those wings with the blue
cheese come back up in the parking
lot you do have to give it up for
buffalo bill fans and their cast iron
stomachs that they can have that many
wings
and beer in their bellies and still
[ __ ] land on their backs on those
[ __ ] tables and not just you know you
would think physics at that point would
take over
and all of that stuff would just come
back up but somehow they they do not
look at big ben he's excited
doing special teams or defense scores a
touchdown the quarterback has to feel
like he got a day off from work and got
paid
oh that's a thing of beauty right there
um
i don't know why am i rooting for the
steelers they were such babies when the
patriots were
[ __ ] great
you know co-signing on everything that
that [ __ ]
jerk off in indianapolis was doing
um
anyway
but why why dig up dead dogs
why dig up dead dogs because we need to
find out what happened to those dogs
um
crazy week on the road you know i've
been out here uh
in new york city i had a great time i
went out to penn state happy valley
and it lived up to its name uh me
joe bartnick and paul verzi
had an amazing show at the uh the
arena there where the penn state
basketball team plays
um
just an awesome crowd you know it was
looked like it was about 50 50 like
locals and college students so i was
kind of concerned you know doing a
college
you know all it takes is one
hairy-legged white chick to just [ __ ]
end your career now
so i was just going like all right
which joke is that chick gonna take
seriously and what's what's the blow
back
what's what's the complete non-story
that's gonna come out so they won't
focus on you know
i guess real issues
um
but nothing happened they were all like
really cool or whatever and then the
next day we went to the [ __ ] um
we went to the uh the penn state versus
ball state
and the line was like 22 points
or 22 and a half
and uh me and verzi wanted to bet penn
state and i'm just like you know i
didn't give a [ __ ] i was like
i never dawned on me that that's a
little more than one than three
touchdowns
not the smartest gambler so he was
trying to buy a point back and we
couldn't do it so we just said [ __ ] it
anyway and what was hilarious is like it
wasn't really a game but for us it was
so we were sitting there flipping out
when they were up at like like 27
7 or something like that
where the hell the score was 20
24 to
10 i can't even remember what it was and
we were like flipping the [ __ ] out
and everybody around us is just looking
at us like what is your deal
you know and i was like that turned
around and saw me go there wasn't a
catch right it wasn't a catch i was like
yelling at this old guy and he's just
looking at me like
i don't know man or you know we're up by
[ __ ] 19.
there's a couple of crazy things the
penn state band came out there right
in the beginning went
playing all the [ __ ] songs so i'm
watching the uh the band doing their
thing
and all of a sudden i'm looking at the
women doing the baton twirling and i
notice this one woman does not have her
baton anymore and she's just miming it
so i'm like she dropped it where is it i
see it laying
right at the bottom of the one of the
big ten on the field
and now she's got to move with the girls
and everybody else is it you know as the
bands doing their formation she's
walking away from it she's down the end
zone i'm like oh this is cool
i'm going to see like when she subtly
tries to pick the thing up so she
[ __ ] walks by it again
then she disappears the whole baton
twirler goes into where the band is
they're surrounded by the band
and all of this [ __ ] oh look at the big
run right this
nice tackle
um
so buffalo driving
buffalo refusing to go down josh allen
leading his team down the field well not
really that was a wonderful handoff
whoever the [ __ ] that is not oj simpson
cutting right cutting left
um
so anyway
i uh
oh jesus they're running downhill now
they're running downhill he's still
going they're 10 they're five
sorry stop down at the 10.
um
just giving it right back
so she doesn't pick up the baton
and then the [ __ ] thing ends
they're playing the national anthem and
the home
of the
brave
and then we all just sit there because
they said there was going to be a
flyover and like after they brave
there was this anticlimactic like 15 20
seconds and then finally two helicopters
flew over
military helicopters and i was joking
with club soda kenny i was like if those
were airplanes they would have been on
time
the old lumber and helicopters were slow
um it was still cool as [ __ ]
and you know what's funny when they said
uh after today's national anthem in
honor of all the victims and the heroes
that lost their lives on 9 11 we're
going to have a flyover and club soda
kenny goes oh
he was like legit excited
kenny loves the cops loves the firemen
loves the military anything security
based and he became like a little kid he
went oh
that's so
anyway to finish the baton story
and the home of the brave 30 seconds
finally the helicopters
fly over right
everybody salutes the troops and then
the band just walks off the field and
the baton is still laying there
and now penn state and ball state
[Music]
out of bounds
uh then penn state and ball state
[ __ ] uh take the field for the
kickoff and the baton is still sitting
there
now i'm sitting there you know
catastrophizing like oh [ __ ] you know
somebody can you turn a knee on that
thing and tear up your knee
so i finally i yell i go there's a baton
on the field and then these chicks in
front of me were like i know we know
we've been watching it and i guess a
bunch of people saw it
so that chick mimon you know without the
[ __ ] baton which i know she was
coached to do oh they're going for a
field goal here buffalo
oh everybody's thinking wide right you
cannot not think wide right when you're
he's going to hook it he's going to hook
it
and he splits the uprights
bringing them to within 7 with 5 23 to
go
ben roethlisberger mike tomlin how are
they going to chew up the clock so the
young kid the young superstar
the man out there in buffalo that most
of the chicks and some of the guys would
drop their buffalo wings to go out and
blow on any random night
can he bring him back can he get the
ball back with enough time
we shall see um
so they kicked the ball off and finally
somebody came down and they yelled to
somebody down on the sideline security
person that there was a baton on the
field and then it went around and around
and around and around around and then
they finally went out somebody got the
thing after like maybe one offensive
play i believe and they brought it off
the field
and we thought the saga was it had ended
but they handed it to the kicker which
we all thought was [ __ ] hilarious
and then eventually you won our bet
which was also nice because they did
cover so thank you to everybody out in
penn state that hooked us up gave us
this whole
you know they gave us all this penn
state gear they gave me some stuff for
my kids
uh which was so nice of them penn state
people were awesome they couldn't have
been nicer
and we got to see you know be amongst
those big ten fans when they found out
ohio state lost to the ducks
you know you know it's funny they lost
to the ducks and i bet 80 percent of
ohio state fans
right now at this moment still thinks
ohio state should be in the playoffs
so um
anyway before the game we were actually
down on the field
which was
[ __ ] amazing and uh
you know
as they ran off the field we're watching
the drills and everything one of the
most amazing things when you're down on
the field is aside from the size and the
speed is when the punter's just kicking
the ball dude the guy kicks it like a
[ __ ] mile in the air i've never seen
anything like it
um
and uh so all the penn state players
were running off the field and all of a
sudden this big linebacker looking dude
for penn state just stops
and says to joe like hey man what's
going on and joe's all like hey what's
going on man and he goes
he's like i you know he goes you didn't
tell me you were coming here and joe was
just kind of like ah you know
it just kind of went with the
at first i thought the kid thought he
was a comedian but with joe's mustache i
guess he looked like one of his former
coaches
and joe like just went with it because
he didn't i don't know what and they
they both give each other this giant
[ __ ] bear
and joe's going like yeah man and the
other guy's like yeah and they hug each
other and then they leave
and i go to joy and go jump tell me man
that mustache is working look at people
remember you
from your comedy because i remember when
i was in atlantic city at the sportsbook
people went right past me and they went
up to him i'm going dude i'm telling you
that [ __ ] mustache
it it it solidifies the whole thing the
[ __ ] that you talk about and how you
look you now look like your act
and that's what i thought it was and he
goes no man he goes i think he thought i
was one of his coaches
i go he thought you were one of the cool
he goes yeah
he's he said hey coach i thought he said
i like your comedy but he said coach
i didn't know you were coming to the
game
and i go what
why did you hug him then he goes i
didn't want to ruin his moment
so what's funny to me
is now that kid is going to [ __ ] text
his coach saying thanks for coming out
and he's going to be like i wasn't at
the game and now he's got to think who
the [ __ ] that who the [ __ ] did i hug
so if anybody from penn state is
listening
from the team
and you hear that kid tell the story
tell him that he hugged joe bartnick the
mike ditka
of uh of stand-up comedy who i think now
we got to call him the coach or coach or
something like that
coach bartnick
um dude you should have seen the hug
that they that he the kid hugged joe
like he really was one of his coaches
and helped him turn turn him into a man
and get him you know strong enough
mentally or whatever the hell the great
things coaches do for these kids to get
him to a division one program so
anyway
there's 5 17 left in the game everybody
it's still 20 to 13 buffalo i already
know that you know the stats
i already know that you know who wins
here
so
this is this is big bend time
you know he's been in the league this
long
and i just think that guy's as good as
ben roethlisberger the only thing that
excites them is shutting up
60 000 fans that ate a bunch of buffalo
wings and thought that they were going
to win today
oh are they going to go conservative and
put it on the [ __ ] ground
ah jesus christ
this [ __ ] i swear to god
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
chewing up the clock and the prevent
defense is a conspiracy by the nfl to
make sure every [ __ ] game as much as
possible comes down to the last
possession all right here we go come on
ben throw the [ __ ] ball
all right
poor excuse for a play action fake to
the back shoulder first down
is that juju something smith smith
shuster
um nice
why am i being a [ __ ] hasn't the buffalo
bills fans suffered enough
didn't i get enough enjoyment
over the years
as a patriots fan
yeah but i went to their their [ __ ]
stadium and i went to take a leak and
somebody pushed me in the back while i
had my dick out because i had a patriots
hat on so i kind of have to have a
little bit of a
[ __ ] them attitude of course now because
now they're talking [ __ ] because they're
good
and they're all excited last year when
they beat the patriots without tom brady
you know what i mean it's like all right
well it took tom brady leaving
[Music]
i don't remember rubbing it in
with you guys when when jim kelly
retired but all right if that's how you
want to do it i get it
you guys jump on tables
um
anyway plowing ahead here i heard
there's an incredible motogp race this
week and i heard the f1 race was great
too and um
i got to be honest with you i am uh
fighting off a major depression here
because i have not been on the road this
long since i've had kids
ever and uh i've just been in a really
[ __ ] uh bad mood
which isn't good because tonight i'm
doing a benefit
you know
for the 20th anniversary of the 911
um
whatever whatever the thing for 9 11
whatever you're supposed to call it and
uh
so i need to get in a happy
benefit mood
um
as i'm sitting here [ __ ] moping
around
just [ __ ] uh
i've had it i want to get back to my
life
i got to get back to my kids and
everything dude my son is so adorable
right now he can wave goodbye now and
you know he kind of opens and closes his
hand but
because he sees the way his view of
doing it he actually is waving goodbye
to himself
so
he doesn't raise his hand either he just
starts he just sort of brings it halfway
up
and goes you know opens and closes his
hand and now he does it with both hands
it's
it's [ __ ]
the most adorable thing ever so
um
yeah that was probably the highlight of
my week this week in new york cause i
went out and i uh
got my daughter a halloween costume and
i bought my son
a little pair of timberlands
which are the cutest things i think i've
ever seen in my life
um
i was just hoping i could find like uh
like
baggy jeans
for like a one-year-old so i could put
those on when he wears the timberland so
he can look like he's in
a reboot of naughty by nature
you know so
anyway i uh i did some spots this week
i went down the village you know there's
a couple of stand-up rooms down there
and i just got freaked out because it
was jam-packed it looked like [ __ ]
mardi gras down there
and people weren't wearing masks and i'm
watching people passing joints to each
other and [ __ ] i was just like all right
i guess this [ __ ] is just what this [ __ ]
is gonna be and people are just sick of
the whole [ __ ] thing
and
there's all of this information
coming from too many [ __ ] places and
it's just it just is what it is i guess
we live in
the world we live in so i was like all
right
uh
all right [ __ ] it i don't care anymore
[Laughter]
how strong you have to be to still care
when nobody else cares is j i i don't
have that i'm just like all right
okay is this what we're doing uh fine so
i still wear a mask i don't even you
know what's funny i don't even know if
it's an effective mask
you know i have one of those ones that
is the effective one but like you can
barely breathe in the thing when it's
hot out here in new york so i was
wearing the cloth one so i probably was
doing more damage than i was doing good
and i was just like i don't know you
know i come home i have my little
mushroom extract i try to have some
vitamin d here or there i guess i don't
[ __ ] know
i don't know what to do here so um
i'm just you know
just gonna [ __ ] live my life right
what am i gonna do okay
that's it i mean
i guess it's just here to stay um all
right now why when i go away do i have
to [ __ ] re-sign back into this
[ __ ] goddamn thing
also i also notice when you're watching
a game it takes more batter even if your
computer is plugged in
um i guess i shouldn't be watching it on
my laptop is that what it is
all right what is this 256 left it's
second and 11.
ben roethlisberger i think versy pic i
think this was a versi pick
i love it
oh they're gonna go home sad and buffalo
with a big
loss
at home
look at this kid now he's got a chain
with a buffalo around it
he went to the gift shop he bought all
this stuff
all right 256 to go ben roethlisberger
lifts the leg up sets it back down i
don't know what that means fades back to
pass
throws it to the [ __ ] ground
third and 11.
took a steve brogan hit slowly gets up
off the turf they just they don't make
him like this guy anymore
this is a dying breed the level of
punishment that this guy can take just
stands there
oh that didn't look that bad
jesus christ he just [ __ ] buried his
face into the turf like he got hit by a
[ __ ] car did that look that bad you
know what that is that's from like 15 16
years of taking hits not to mention i'm
sitting here on a couch josh allen hey
man i thought we were gonna win
all right
he's touching his shoulders he's
bringing his hands together there's some
sort of audible oh looks like buffalo
bills are coming here they oh no
and they get nothing they sniff that out
247 left buffalo's gonna get the ball
back
unless they're close enough for a field
goal because i have not been paying
attention isn't as exciting for all you
guys listening to this podcast that
don't watch nfl football and what am i
gonna do as head coach
that's redneck me
that's if i knew how to hunt me with the
[ __ ] the head coach of the bills with
his camouflage hat
you know look at him he looks like he's
at peace you know
he's not worried about the dollar
collapsing he knows at any point he can
[ __ ] take out his slingshot take out
a squirrel
and make some stew
oh my god look at this puncher this guy
looks like he's about 12 [ __ ] years
old ro he still has rosy cheeks
is he still teething what [ __ ] old is
this kid oh it's a field goal kicker
did they just say he's been in the
league 14 years
was he also balding
my eyes are going i just saw the picture
of him
look like rich eisen all right here we
go
there he's on the hat we're right side
hash mark the kick is up
oh
and he splits the uprights
how to put them down by two scores
oh there you go ben roethlisberger
hurting a little bit less josh allen
wondering why you ever left idaho
big time kick
lace is out number nine
splits the uprights
bills mafia
who they gonna blame this time pat
mcgroder
um
oh look at that
look at that buffalo's head coach that
looks like me when a new joke doesn't
work
um what's with the [ __ ] steelers hats
too like they just they have a circle is
all in yellow and then you can't even
see their logo
is that supposed to make me look at it
closer is it supposed to add an air of
mystery
to ben roethlisberger roethlisberger
however you say it
um
so anyway
somebody trash in hollywood i always get
these emails of people trash in
hollywood it's just like i don't
understand have you ever been out here
all your pedophiles out and [ __ ] it yeah
but david oh yeah there's no pedophiles
where you live
i'm sorry
oh a pedophile is a person in your
neighborhood oh a sex offender is a
person in your neighborhood
in your neighborhood
in your neighborhood does it sound like
i'm just stretching right now because it
should cause i'm still waiting for kyler
murray i'm still waiting for the reads
here
i'm still waiting for the reads
well i think you know barring a miracle
alcoa presents
fantastic finishes
i'm going to call it early here like a
presidential election
truman loses okay wait a minute i got
the reads i got the reads simply safe
everybody
isn't that what we all want to be you
know there's big news from my favorite
home security company simply safe
unlike the
nfl [ __ ] sunday ticket simply safe is
easy to install
they just launched their new wireless
outdoor security camera that's right
simply safe the system that u.s news and
world report names the best home
security system of 2021 just got even
better the brand new outdoor security
camera is engineered with all the
advanced technology and security
features you want and need to help keep
you and your family safe it has an ultra
wide 140 degree field of view
so you can keep
uh watch over your entire yard
it has 180 p whatever that means hd
resolution with an x zoom that means you
can tell if it's your neighbor
is that mike
sort of a [ __ ] of stealing my tractor
that means you can zoom in and clearly
see things like faces and license plates
to capture critical evidence it has a
built-in spotlight with color night
vision so you can keep an eye on what's
going on day and night it's super simple
to set up and ease and usually just
takes minutes
and it has an easy to remove
rechargeable battery so it does doesn't
need an outlet and can go anywhere on
your property this camera has it all and
integrates with your simply safe home
security system extending its protection
to the outside together it means every
door
window and room are protected and now
your property will too uh will be two
sorry to learn more about the exciting
new simply safe wireless outdoor
security camera visit simply safe.com
what's more
uh simply safe for celebrating this new
camera by offering 20 off your entire
new system and your first month in
monitoring service free
uh when you enroll in interactive
monitoring again that's simply safe.com
oh look who it is everybody indochino
you know
it may have been a while since the last
time you had an excuse to dress up
but whenever
that chance uh next chance is make the
absolute most of it with indochino oh
it's gonna happen now everybody's done
everybody's done on the left and right
everybody's back
you know the rights just like i ain't
getting no [ __ ] vaccination [ __ ] you
i got the sniffles i need to go to the
hospital that's how they are and then
the left is all like i have the
vaccination and here's my card so i can
do whatever the [ __ ] i want
um
anyway uh but whenever that next chance
is i think it's gonna be right now
indochino offers completely custom
fitted suits shirts casual wear and and
more at surprisingly affordable prices
every piece is made to your exact
measurements and you can customize every
detail choose everything about your suit
from the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings you can create a suit
that fits you and your style perfectly
the best part in no cheeto suits started
just in 3.99 with all customizations
included indochino is now open to
select nordstrom groups giving you even
more ways to get great fitting
personalized clothing find your nearest
location at indochino.com
uh right now you can get fifty dollars
off any purchase of 399 or more by using
the code bur at checkout that's fifty
dollars off a purchase at 399 or more at
i n d o
a
india november delta oscar charlie hotel
india november oscar for you pilots dot
com promo code bur
b-u-r-r all right
two minutes left
now what do you do if you're the
pittsburgh steelers it's like you're
just you are gonna let them score
that's the rule you stop playing defense
with two minutes to go and what you
really try to do is just keep the ball
in the uh the field of play
to try to burn down the clock it is the
two minute warning here
and now they have gone to commercial
which gives me time to read
whatever the [ __ ] people wrote this week
um
click to exit full screen
full screen
come on man just just just let me get to
my [ __ ] goddamn emails here can you
do that for me
all right
airplane is a remake sort of oh don't do
this to me bill needs to is a kentucky
fried movie what was first bill needs to
watch this youtube video it tells the
story of how airplane was virtually a
shot for shot oh yeah yeah like those
airport movies
of another remake of another movie but
played for comedy versus drama
definitely worth the watch thanks you
won't be disappointed
yeah they had all of those george
kennedy movies
it was a spoof
of uh
of those movies all right so i'm
watching it right now
zero hour 1957. oh okay
i didn't know that
now somebody tried to tell me that
robert stack didn't even get the movie
um
oh [ __ ] this is my kids facetime me i
gotta hit pause
all right i'm back
i'm not really back i [ __ ]
somehow recorded the last 20 minutes of
the podcast and i didn't have the record
on because i don't know what i did wrong
so at this point um watching the
patriots vs the dolphins and the
dolphins jesus oh geez they went right
down the field
with teo
tuga viola
tago viola
sounds like a pitcher biola
um
just shredded our defense just ran down
the field like we weren't even there
uh mac jones first pass of his nfl
career
good zip on the ball first down so the
the mac jones era
has begun chains are out there looking
to see if it was a first down but you
guys don't want to know this
you guys want to hear what i have to say
to you guys with about the whole [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that you wrote i'm going to
re-read i literally just
did this
i just did this
ah fourth in inches you [ __ ] all
right
here's somebody writes in airplane which
by the way is a movie that i was talking
about that i really enjoyed
um
that i watched again and it totally
holds up like ace ventura pet detective
uh airplane is a remake sort of
of this movie uh zero hour from 1957.
it's almost a frame by frame
i guess remake of that movie combined
with uh
all of those great airport movies that i
used to watch there was these tv movies
that i can't even tell you what a
friggin event it was
there was like airport 70s i don't know
what airport 75 airport 77
and then there was [ __ ] uh the last
one
i want to say it was like airport 81
i forget what it was but it was like
george kennedy was always flying a plane
i remember the first one
it might have just been called airport
and this guy got on a plane
and you know he he brought a bomb on and
i don't know what he went to the
bathroom he blew out the half the
[ __ ] back of the plane they got to
land the thing right
probably not the best thing to talk
about uh 20-year anniversary in 911 but
you know this is what you guys wrote in
so here we go and then the next one
was um
don't even [ __ ] say a [ __ ] ball
god damn it fumble patriots you
[ __ ]
that was shaping up to be a nice drive
there
um let's see is this is his knee down is
the knee down does the ball come out
ah couldn't tell from that angle that
didn't look like a oh come on what the
[ __ ]
that's not a fumble
so anyway
probably wasn't the best angle we'll see
so anyway um then they had it was such a
hit you know hollywood it's like well
they liked it let's do it again
then they did airport 75 there with that
i think that one that landed in the
[ __ ] ocean
and they were under water
and they needed somebody to save them
somehow raise them up
and then there was uh
airport 77 i forget what happened on
that one
and uh i just remember the last one
george kennedy was flying the uh the
concorde
which was something i always wanted to
do was to fly the concord from um
supersonic plane from um which i don't
even know what that means faster than
the speed of sound maybe
from new york to uh
france i actually took a picture of the
plane one time
i was walking through kennedy airport in
like the late 90s
i just saw it it was like famous it was
[ __ ] iconic it was one of the sickest
looking planes ever
and uh unfortunately they had that crash
i believe a tire
the tire blew and went up into the
engine or something like that during
takeoff and they slammed into a uh
a hotel well that's uplifting bill well
that's what happened and then they did
away with it and there hasn't been
another supersonic jet since
as far as a passenger one
but anyway so then
airplane the movie came out making fun
of those movies but i guess it's also
that movie zero hour which i will
definitely check out
um from 1957. as i told you guys i like
to disappear
into the past
that's how i handle the news and all of
that [ __ ] i just [ __ ] watch that [ __ ]
so all right let's get on to your next
question that i've already [ __ ]
answered that you guys will never hear
the answer to
um screaming oh by the way the name of
that youtube video is uh side by side
comparison
uh airplane versus zero hour
now if you want to check that out at
work or whatever it is you're doing all
right screaming at the top of your lungs
oh that is something i did today
i didn't want to disturb people in the
hotel here
i was trying to sign on to nfl ticket i
literally put my hand over my mouth and
i was just like why is this so [ __ ]
difficult
um
all right screaming at the top of your
line it's really
i don't know if it's the direct tv
website
it's like it just goes to this [ __ ]
page that tries to get you to sign up
for it and once you've already signed up
for it it's like that you still open it
up on that page and what you have to do
is
click on something on the right and then
click on watch
and then you're okay
um
so anyway
they called that a fumble
i must have had a bad angle
jesus christ patriots looking to be down
and i bet the patriots this week i also
bet the [ __ ] cardinals so that was a
good pick let's see this where does the
ball come out
oh that was close i think that was a
good call
you won't see it on this angle
i don't know
it was one of those things probably uh
there wasn't enough conclusive evidence
all right screaming at the top of your
lungs which i think i'm going to be
doing if the [ __ ] dolphins go up 14
to nothing
come on come on please stop the run
there we go
third down they're gonna be out of field
goal range here but i love it
i love it unless we [ __ ] blow it here
on third down
okay hey bill lady listener here
i've been a big fan for over a year now
sorry i'm late to the party and thanks
for the laughs i'm an opera singer
well geez louise i mean you guys are
some of the best singers on the planet
you guys are like you know
whatever auto-tune is you you guys are
the opposite of that
um
i'm an opera singer so keeping my voice
healthy is a top priority in my field
watching your specials i'm amazed how
you can scream so much during your shows
and seemingly never become hoarse
i definitely if i do a couple of shows
you know if i do like five or six shows
i will definitely get hoarse or if i
screw up
and come from uh my voice box area as
opposed to my diaphragm
i will be in trouble uh my question for
you is how have you lasted all these
years without completely destroying your
voice
i'd love to know your secret uh it is no
secret and i'm actually scared that
you're con as someone who sings
professionally that you're afraid for me
um
so uh watching the replay here did we
sack him did we sack him did we sack him
did we yes baby whoa
[ __ ] you
love it
dolphins back to punt
from their own 41 yard line come on take
it back one time one time just take it
back here
nice kick nice kick doesn't fair catch
sidestep's the first guy we got a white
guy and he is on the ground
that was all right i think he's kind of
fast all right
here we go
mac jones coming out for the second
possession um i actually messed up my
voice early on in my career imitating
how my dad would cough and then try to
draw air in you made this really crazy
sound that i i still won't do because it
i can't even do it anymore but i did it
every night on stage as part of a bit
back when people smoked in the clubs and
i didn't realize i was destroying my
voice i can't even do the impression
anymore
so um i know i've done damage over the
years probably but um
early on
i was really you know
you know when i wanted to yell i just
came from my throat
so i actually took singing lessons from
this old guy in boston that barely
charged any money on my comm ave way
back in the day and the rumor was that
early on he actually helped stephen
tyler with his voice and if you notice
the difference between i don't know if
that's true or not but if you notice
difference between stephen tyler's voice
on the first album
aerosmith versus get your wings
um his voice sounds way better on the
second one and sounds different like the
first album it doesn't even sound like
him and i think he
probably you know heard his voice and
eventually went to this guy
but whatever the guy was great and he
kind of taught me how
basically to yell
and not come from uh my voice
my throat area that's how
i i try to avoid it
um
you know and there's other tricks that i
can just do like
like not yelling
and just being silly or whatever but i
will be honest with you the fact that
you're wondering how i haven't done
permanent damage destroying my voice
it actually makes me a little concerned
maybe because i've screamed my whole
[ __ ] life i have a stronger
vocal cords
[Laughter]
they've been training i don't know i
have a temper so i don't know maybe
maybe that's it i have no idea so anyway
plowing ahead here wedding advice don't
do it no
uh wedding advice bill of fatty making
fun of fatty's birth well jesus christ
if that isn't the truest statement ever
made
um
and by the way i gave in to the
temptation of the deli got a bacon egg
and cheese last night need a pint of ice
cream i did that two nights ago too so
but i've been here for a number of days
i only did it two nights out of like
seven so
it still was bad but i'm not gonna do it
tonight okay
uh bill fatty making fun of fatty's burr
i have a small wedding i'm the best man
uh coming up and wanted to know what you
think about my toast
um i'm so dumb i thought you literally
meant your toast like okay what do you
you burn it up what's the deal
you're not talking about that toast what
you think of the toast you will be
making are it will be my friends and
family a destination wedding only the
grandparents
are conservative everyone else is pretty
cool
i was going to open up with the joke and
then proceed to be more heartfelt about
the bride and groom well that's a great
strategy that's the old school
roast
that's the way the old school roasts
were the new school roast is you just
i don't know what it is you just don't
even know the person you eviscerate them
and then really quickly you go hey man i
always liked you
um i like i like your game plan here he
goes here is what i was going to open
with
hello i'm the best man and i have known
the groom since we were kids in fact i
even remember his first girlfriend oh
jesus uh the relationship didn't last
long though she took forever to download
and he was getting carpal tunnel
does that suck
any advice is good
keep up the hard work all right that
would bomb in a comedy club but i mean
it's not a bad
it's not a bad joke as far as joke
structure um
you are bringing up past relationships
you are sort of alluding to him jerking
off to the internet
i don't know how [ __ ] cool people are
i don't know how much rum you're gonna
be drinking on the island or whatever
you're going to at all you just read the
room i mean personally i would go
with a story first down patriots i would
go with the story that um
i mean if you're the best man you got to
be like best buds with this guy don't
you guys have stories
of [ __ ] that you've done together
that you did together and you know
some knucklehead story of the two of you
guys that kind of makes fun of both of
you
as opposed to bringing up the fact even
though you're talking about you know
him you know
just jerking off to internet porn you
are kind of bringing up past
relationships i don't know
i would read the room it's not a bad
joke it's a good wedding joke
um
yeah but
you got to have a funny [ __ ] story
somebody locking their keys out of the
car you were drunk or the time you went
on a road trip and it didn't [ __ ]
it's something just i i would try to
keep it light the last thing you want to
do is is
become a moment in the wedding
okay it's not your day it's not even
your buddy's day it's her day okay
that's what the deal is and where are
the feminists on that day they don't
give a [ __ ] that it's not a celebration
of both people it's really her day and
if she's happy it's a good wedding
you know
which really sets the tone for the
marriage
because it's all about if she's happy
then you can relax and maybe enjoy
some of the day until she's upset that's
kind of how it works
all right trying to become a reader
oh dude preaching to the choir dear
billy bookworm
my kid has read a lot of books for
school i envy the way he can just sit in
a chair for an hour and read a book
yeah i envy that too it must be nice to
take your imagination for a spin and
check out the world i've never been able
to do this but i'm trying more these
days well that's good
uh it'd be nice to be all ooh
ah
about some fantasy [ __ ] or even a crime
novel
i got five pages into a book that i was
really enjoying but got distracted by a
work call
that was three weeks ago i know you read
books here and there yeah
more more more there than here
and i was wondering if you have any
tricks for shutting down your medieval
mind hey man
taking shots at me uh what do you do
before you read that helps clear your
mind
or what are you going or what are you
doing to stay
or what are you doing to stay with your
head in the book thanks for the help oh
i have
brutal concentration problems uh
especially when it comes to reading so
um i definitely have to not have
anything that i'm stressing about
in my life
although that [ __ ] has to be out of the
way and if i'm actually gonna read the
book that my phone can't be around on or
anywhere near me
and i also can't be uh
anywhere near um
you know a tv
other people
or whatnot so and then i just you know i
go with light reading
you know
i don't read war and peace i read like
the jack lambert story you know
i'm not like
i just pick a subject that's light
you know
and and
i don't know if you kind of start with
easier books
that don't have a lot of
small prints and and a ton of pages
because i definitely find like you know
i don't know everything to me becomes
like the goal
like this is a 400 page book okay if i
read 50 pages a night i can finish it in
eight days
rather than just going into it like i'm
gonna read till i'm tired and i'll stop
you know when i diet i do the same thing
i'm gonna lose two three pounds of luck
a week time seven weeks and i will lose
my 21 pounds that i need to lose rather
than just being like hey i'm going to
change the way i eat and
that's another reason why i got to get
off the [ __ ] road because i mean
there's only so many times you you know
it's just
i don't know
every place you go to is somewhere
different and trying to drag your ass
down to the gym yet also conserve
yourself so you're going to get to the
show and trying to get sick
it becomes like you know
and then you're hangry and all of that
you order something [ __ ] awful
i'm sorry bill was this question about
you and your road schedule no it wasn't
so that's what i would do i would pick
an easy book that isn't too many pages
and i would get rid of all distractions
around you and and just be like i'm
going to get through five pages
start off with small goals
and walk it down
patriots first down and 10
on the 30-yard
almost an interception
um
i like this kid man he's got some zip on
the ball
pocket passer
see what happened here he lead him a
little too much yes he did
all right let's get to the next question
here no you know what i'm going to watch
the next play sorry i just want to see
this next play
all right 13 36
to go in the second quarter for those of
you playing at home
um
all right for some reason they're
showing the worst dress coach in the nfl
all right second at 10. mac jones pitch
out
all right four or five yards we'll take
that we will take that all day long no
flags
i love it
all right let's get to kid girlfriend's
sister
uh jeez
what do you want to do the combo platy
you trying to bang her too hey billy red
balls i'm 20 and i've been dating my
girlfriend for a few years now it's been
going great however she has a younger
sister that won't shut up
okay she has a younger sister that won't
shut up third and six sorry you're gonna
have to i gotta watch a little bit of
this drive here
mac jones oh with the completion out of
the flat i love it down to the [ __ ]
12-yard line
in bill belichick we trust this kid
looks all right i know it's just the
dolphins
i know it's just the first or second
quarter of the first game of the year
i like the play calling
that guy wearing jim plunkett's old
number
corey myers
all right
what do we got here all right mack jones
first and 10 12 20 to go
under center the center's confused he's
talking to people he hikes the ball mac
jones
goes with his second option corny enzo
throws it away smart play smart play all
right here we go um i'm 20 and i've been
dating
she talks [ __ ] and brings up how in high
school i used to smoke ganja all the
time i don't anymore i've been pulling
my life together i don't smoke i work
out i even started college
for psychology good for you but nothing
changes her opinion of me well why do
you give a [ __ ] what she thinks
my girlfriend and her mom has tried
helping but it's gone nowhere well
that's good that they're on your side
anyway i feel like a [ __ ] just letting
her walk all over me because if i do
speak up it will not be nice at all she
still thinks i'm some sort of hooligan
who doesn't do [ __ ] she hates men and
only really respects any guys who are
drop dead gorgeous i say this because
i've only heard her talk good about
dudes who are sculpted like greek gods
she does swing both ways and i even her
and even her on-again off-again
girlfriend trash me
no jesus well i mean you know her
girlfriend in her defense her idea of
you is from her girlfriend so
i try being nice by buying her christmas
gifts and birthday gifts she will then
be nice for one day but immediately
after she goes back to trashing me and
hating me all right so what you have on
your hands here is a [ __ ]
so
what you should
what you should do
what i would do
the first thing you do
is be really nice to her girlfriend
always compliment her
hey i really like that shirt
laugh at her jokes
just always say something nice hey good
to see you
you know what i mean just divide and
conquer and then when her [ __ ] of a
sister gives you [ __ ]
just agree with her
smoke ganja i'm [ __ ] dealing now
i actually have some buried under the
house i'm going to take you guys all
down with me i would just do that
sarcasm agree with her
and
you know just laugh
and just then it becomes a one-sided war
i think the reason why she's still doing
this to you aside from maybe some
personal issues
is that she sees that it's getting to
you and she's getting a rise from you
um he says here in the last paragraph
she's a hurt human who causes a lot of
her own issues and she's very
hypocritical
sounds like your standard human being i
mean you just described me
myself as well as her family don't know
how don't know what to do i started i'm
starting to hate being around my
girlfriend's house and i love her
family so it's hard any advice
will help by the way nice show in boston
thank you well thank you for coming out
i would just have fun with it dude
um
you're letting a person that has no
effect on your life
uh another fumble by the patriots
recovered thank christ johnny on the
spot number 60.
um
[Music]
yeah
it just you just there's no reason to
let this person affect you all right you
know why she's doing this [ __ ] it has
nothing to do with you that did just
kill the drive son of a [ __ ]
all right here comes the field
folk
oh keith folk was good luck for the red
sox
there we go
he's written more like folk music
you know i was thinking this the other
day did you hear um
i guess at one point donald trump
told his followers to get the
vaccination and then they booed him
i got such a kick out of that if that
even happened i didn't see it somebody
told me that that happened they booed
him and then i was thinking like you
know what that must that's like
the politician equivalent of like when
bob dylan went electric
you know he was playing acoustic and
everybody's like yeah man coffee house
acoustic and then he came out electric
and then all his fans were like
do what you always did
i feel like that's what happened to him
um like i said even if in fact if that
even happened anyway that is the podcast
uh to that last kid just [ __ ] have
fun with it just agree with her
you [ __ ] pothead i know
you know thank god i haven't moved on to
coke yet or have i i would just do that
and then to say to a girlfriend hey you
know you get i like your shirt
just do that
i just have a [ __ ] great time with it
and um
you know
i guess that's what you have to do i
don't know i it's it's too bad you're
dealing with that but just know that
eventually
um if that if her sister continues to go
the route she's going she's you know
it's going to be a train wreck which you
really shouldn't wish on anybody but if
she's being an [ __ ] to you at least
it won't feel tragic
you can maybe kind of enjoy the fact
that she's uh completely
miserable because that's what she sounds
like
you know
but whatever you do
don't get mad at her
you know and say something [ __ ] up
because then she'll use that against you
she'll just try to have a good time all
right so that's it everybody that is the
podcast by the way
how about
the a.l east
the yankees who just took command
winning 13 in a row of all of a sudden
you know lost all these [ __ ] games
like 10 out of 11 or something nuts they
won last night on 9 11 against the mets
and i don't know where the toronto
[ __ ] you know i'm not going to say
maple leafs if we're talking playoffs
the toronto [ __ ] blue jays are
actually in it so now it's a three-way
race and everyone was predicting this
red sox yankees and for all you know one
of somebody might go home
well there's three people for two slots
so at some point the song stops and only
two people have a chair there right
um yankees could go home the red sox go
home and maybe [ __ ] uh
what do you call it there the [ __ ] um
the blue jays who knows who knows
um all right that's it i'm gonna watch
the mac jones era here it is seven to
three um and i'm liking what i'm seeing
so far all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll check in on you
on thursday see ya